marquez le bonsoir et bienvenue dans un autre
épisode de Grave Encounters,
tout comme les hôpitaux de York comme celui-ci,
nous sommes considérés comme une sorte de dépotoir
pour les membres de la famille embarrassants plutôt
que comme un endroit où ils pourraient aller
pour obtenir de l'aide,
beaucoup d'entre eux ont été gravement perturbés  vraiment
effrayant je jure devant Dieu que j'ai vu
quelqu'un faire une descente au bout du couloir frapper
et il jure que quelque chose l'a
poussé de l'échelle
vous les gars avez vu cette fenêtre ici verrouillez-
la vraiment bien la nuit revenez le
matin sifflant parfois pourquoi le faire
ce soir,
mon équipage et moi utilisons l'
équipement de chasse aux fantômes le plus sophistiqué,
nous sommes à la recherche de preuves définitives d'
esprits qui ont été perturbés dans la vie et
peut-être perturbés dans l'au-delà,
y a-t-il quelqu'un ici avec nous qui est que si
c'est quelque chose de réel avez-vous obtenu  ce
TC Roma ouais
je vais tout documenter parce que nous, les
bonnes personnes, voudrons voir ce
Mack à Houston oh ouais nous devons juste nous
concentrer sur Bonnie nous sommes
oh ouais
hé  Hé qui es-tu, comment se fait-il que tu sois
ici